if you were a kid in the 90s you might
remember this show legends
of the hidden temple
this guy was the host kirk fogg
thank you thank you nice to see you
legends of the hidden temple for those
who didn't watch it was an iconic game
show out of the 90s by nickelodeon
are you ready olmec let's rock barely
anybody won there were 120 shows and
like only 30 winners teams are you ready
i guess now we can finally get answers
to all of our legends of the hidden
temple questions who was olmec
yeah as it turns out there was a guy
standing inside his face but he stands
back there and he has a microphone here
his copy here and he has his hand on the
lever that handles the mouth i'm gonna
ruin it for all the kids
a lot of people ask who were the temple
guards
they were the guys who used to help out
during the show but here's a little
behind the scenes secret occasionally
some of the writers would dress up i
think they vicariously got a thrill out
of scaring the crap out of kids going to
that temple
i felt bad for a few of them but they
really did scare the crap out of kids
this poor girl got really super upset in
the middle of the run and she threw up
and unfortunately she threw up in the
pit of despair oh god everybody asked
what was the hardest room and i think
probably for everybody it was the shrine
or the silver monkey these three
things look similar together because
they're kind of all silver so you have
to kind of stack them on turn it around
no turn the head around i was actually
an expert at it
so yeah the temple was pretty impossible
is that the only reason there were so
few winners the producers were only
allowed to give out eight championships
a year so there was a budget
and that's the
truth of that oh no oh yeah
you